all right let's go back to the phones at
six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty and see if we've got things
working once again let's try our caller
from the nine three six area code caller
from nine three six can you hear me if
so what's your name where are you
calling from
hey David this is Robert from Houston
hey Robert what's going on hey I was
curious if you saw the Tim Poole
amphitheater interview I saw like five
minutes of it yeah and I mean what from
what I saw Sam was making a lot of sense
and I wasn't exactly sure you know Tim
seem to be making a point but then back
very quickly backing away from it when
Sam would challenge it and then I got
bored and I went on to other things
that's that's about the right reaction
he should have had I mean what did you
make of it what was the demo what was
the gist of their discussion even about
it had to do with impeachment Noah then
drifted off into sort of other niche
topics but I'm trying to figure out
where Tim Poole lands like in the space
of the political sphere if he's like
like a leftist I know that you've you've
talked to him before you said that
you're friendly with him yeah like off
the air and stuff it's it's just kind of
strange to see somebody who's I guess
reported leftist but who like constantly
defends Trump and another conservative
talking point yeah listen I mean I think
Tim is playing and I would say this to
his face and I've said if I I think that
Tim's personal politics on an
issue-by-issue basis I believe that they
are left and he recently did a political
compass test and posted it and he's on
the left according to his issue-by-issue
positions I think that he has found that
it is good business to play the sort of
enlightened post partisan centrist
and to take the position that he's
calling out the excesses as he sees them
of the anti-trump media as he sees them
and it's profitable and it's getting him
a lot of attention and you know but
privately he's four you know he checks a
lot of the boxes that left his check
about medicare-for-all and whatever
other I think that that's basically
what's going on with Tim Poole
okay make sense okay well thanks for
taking my call David have a good day all
right you too appreciate the phone call
thank you